it's so nice to be outdoors again and to
get my daily steps in today i'm going to
take you on a walking adventure with
pikmin bloom special thanks to google
play for sponsoring this video we know
that staying active is extremely
important not just for your physical
health but for your mental health as
well so why not make it more fun and
join me in the playmakers flower power
fitness challenge so i'm going to be
taking my first 10k steps today in honor
of pikmin blooms community day
and let's make every step count okay
so before i start walking i'm going to
start flower planting and as i'm walking
i'm going to be planting flowers along
my journey to make this park really
beautiful and comfortable for my pikmin
i mean seriously this app is such a fun
and engaging way to get us outdoors and
really to get our steps in
it makes me want to walk further
and before i know it i'm already close
to hitting my 10 000 steps so guys
get outside it's going to be really good
for your mood for your energy level and
it's going to make you really happy as
well so i'm going to grow my seedlings
into pikmin by walking more
and i'm also going to fit the nectar to
my pikmin to collect more petals for
flower planting
one thing i love about being outdoors is
to fit in a quick five-minute total body
heat workout to really get my heart rate
up and burn more calories so we've
warmed up by walking around the park now
let's do this with me okay whether
you're in the park or at home so only 40
seconds for each workout and 20 seconds
rest this is your challenge let's go tap
down
and go to the right
tap
side to side shuffle
making sure they are squatting low
and we want to really power through
using your legs tap
good job
and this is also going to help us to get
our steps in
it's a big space so play and enjoy the
space
tap
last few more
oh i can feel the burn
and
oh my gosh i know all right still
working on our lower body still working
on explosive movements okay next workout
is going to be a shuffle with plyo
lunges alright so start easy
shuffle
and we want to add
two
plyo lunges okay let's go
shuffle
and two
plyo lunges
good
if this is too difficult you can just go
with static lunges shuffle
static lunge step forward step back and
back if not let's go
explosive movement
one up
power
through
whoa
ah
it's such a beautiful day
being outdoor
oh
keep going
just few more
shuffle
let's go fly your
lunges
and up
all right
catch your breath
breathe in
breathe in and grab some water if you
need to
next
let's work on
forward squat jump
with a quick run back okay so if you
want to step slightly back
give me two
forward squat jump
all right
and take a shot
jock back
jump
and jog
good job
again
if this is too much for you
what you can do is squat step forward
squat step forward
and run back
so choose your option okay
what i want you to
do
is to follow along
listen to your body
and
get active
run back a few more
jump forward
and
run back okay
all right i know
my hydrate is going crazy all right now
let's get down onto the floor we're
going to go with brick dancer and a knee
tuck a really fun move so
get into a high plank position
release your hand
into a brake dancer
and
two
knee tucks
okay let's try it release
kick it
to detox
good
up
to
detox and
one more
tuck it in
feel your abs
[Music]
kick as high as you can
knee tucks
you got this okay you're almost there
that's one more
and come back up
i've grass in my hands but it's all good
okay one final workout to end this five
minute hit challenge we're going to end
with simple jumping jacks just to
increase your heart rate and slowly
bring your heart rate back down are we
ready let's go jumping jacks
pace your breathing
breathe in and breathe out
reach your arms as high as you can
and keep breathing okay
a quick five minute workout
but this is a really good fat burning
circuit
stay with me
we're almost at the finishing line
almost there
in
three
two
one
ah
very very well done
well done
i hope your heart rate is as high as
mine right now
okay
and time for a quick selfie
i've hit my steps i've done a quick five
minute hit workout and i'm feeling
really good and this is also my favorite
part where i'm able to lock and reflect
on my day with my pikmin so i'm able to
see how many steps i've hit and where
i've been i'm also able to lock how i
felt
add a picture
and
lock my notes
and i'm also able to look back at all my
previous logs and track my progress
another favorite feature is the social
aspect so i'm going to invite my friends
to play pikmin bloom and encourage them
to get active
and i get to also interact with them by
sending them postcards i mean this is
such a great way to keep each other
accountable while having fun together
this app has encouraged me to keep my
phone in my pocket as i go about my
daily activities that's because i want
to be able to lock my steps and grow new
pigment bodies i mean this is seriously
such a fun and engaging way to motivate
us to stay active and hit our daily
steps so be sure to download pikmin
bloom on google play and
hit your first 10 000 steps today